do you feel like because I do I I I
don't think um
artists
at least even five ten years back
appreciate the radio promo run like they
used to you know what I mean like I feel
like a lot of these younger guys didn't
necessarily break on radio and or
understand the importance of radio or do
you notice that in terms of like certain
artists maybe not wanting to do
you know come to the station or do a
radio run or do like a promo show [__]
like that not a lot but some yeah
um again just not well educated I think
they've fallen into the fantasy of
streaming which you know I don't
necessarily buy it buy it all that it's
legitimate I I think if you want to be a
household name though you want to be on
the radio yeah I always tell everybody I
say look you have a career you could be
big you get but if you win a number one
record
especially markets like La where people
are always in the car right like you
know and
you know people always talk about you
know radios ability to survive man like
the best talent in the world is on the
radio like you know you could you could
you could put on a playlist but I'd
rather hear you and James talk about
something and then play my favorite
record or you and big right or The
Breakfast Club or we just have a lot of
great talent in our stable and you know
I think they're they're gonna take us
into the next that's what I was gonna
say in terms of like obviously radio as
an industry is like shrinking in terms
of like the amount of bodies that are
around like yeah like even like on the
record side you know people are getting
let go it's it just it feels like more
and more the if you think I like the UK
and they have BBC do you feel like
eventually they'll be like some I don't
think they'll ever be like a BBC type
situation in the US I just think there's
too many companies involved yeah but do
you feel like eventually they'll be
something similar where it's like this
is the morning show for the US this is
the you know what I mean like do you
feel like it's gonna get there or or no
I don't think so because I think
I I think big makes sense for LA right I
think didn't make sense for New York he
was on 97 for a little bit no yeah I
probably never told him this story but I
remember my boss calling me and saying
hey should should we do this and and I
met big loved him and I think you know
growing up in New York City I was like
no it's a different vibe you know 100
there's cities there's cities that are
like that yeah like he's one of the
funniest most talented people I've ever
met for sure and and I mean that
sincerely but New York is just a
different animal and New Yorkers are
they want to hear New Yorkers on the
radio they want to know you're there
they want to know yeah and you got to
have a look you know it could be a
little nasty at times you know and
that's their expectation and they
deserve to get what it is that they want
you know